[موسيقى]
اكبر طائره ركاب في العالم كسرت قواعد
الفيزياء وسطع نجمها في السماء عملاق يزن
560 طنا يحلق كطائر نشيد
انها طائره الركاب ايرباص اي 380 واخر
صناعه الطيران الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
تتكون من طابقين وتحتوي على ارقى درجه سفر
اولى بالعالم غرف بخمس نجوم ووسائل راحه
لا تجدها الا في اغلى الفنادق وليس هذا
فحسب فهي ايضا تستطيع نقل ما يعادل عدد
سكان قريه صغيره دفعه واحده لمسافات طويله
ودون التوقف للتزود بالوقود
بتاريخ 18 من يناير عام 2005 شاهد العالم
اول ظهور لهذه الطائره شركه ايرباص اعلنت
عن هذا العملاق بتكلفه انتاج بلغت نحو 11
مليار دولار لانتاج اول دفعه منها ايرباص
سعد بانتاج هذا الوحش لتحدي هيمنه طائره
بوينج 747
الامريكيه في سوق الرحلات الطويله
اول نوع من الطائره الكبرى سلمى الى
الخطوط الجويه السنغافوريه في الخامس عشر
من اكتوبر عام 2007 في ذلك الوقت بلغ
انتاج الطائره ذروته بحدود 30 طائره سنويا
بين عامي 2012 و 2014
اليوم هناك 228 طائره من اي 300 في الخدمه
حول العالم فيما تعد خطوط طيران الامارات
اكبر مشغل للطائره ب 115 منها في الخدمه
380 يصل سعرها الى 400 مليون دولار وهي
كبيره جدا بحيث يمكنها حمل
853 راكبا كحد اقصى ورغم هذا الحجم الكبير
تستطيع الطائره التحليق بسلاسه وسهوله
بالاعتماد على محركاتها الاربعه النفاثه
من شركه روز رويس التي تزيد قوتها بمقدار
30% عن محركات طائره 747
الطائره تزين 560 طنا بطول
72.72 متر وارتفاع 24 مترا فيما يصل اقصى
مدى لها الى 15,200 كيلومتر واقصى ارتفاع
تصل اليه يبلغ
14,600 متر
قام الطائره اي 380 الايقونيه باكثر من
800 الف رحله نقلت فيها اكثر من 300 مليون
مسافر منذ دخولها الخدمه
الملايين حول العالم يحلمون بخفض تجربه
السفر بهذا العملاق الطائر لكن حلمهم قد
يكون مهددا فضخامه حجم هذه الطائره جعلت
كلفه تشغيلها وصيانتها ضخمه جدا على خطوط
الطيران وبالتالي قد تضطر بعض منها الى
الاستغناء عن خدماتها
[موسيقى]